merci Emmanuel Capu de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure et lui
de Maine-et-Loire monte du groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
on va bien sur longuement revenir sur ce
qui se passe au Sénat sur l'examen de
cette réforme des retraites mais d'abord
une autre question d'actualité Emmanuel
Macron à annoncé un projet de loi dans
les prochains mois qui vise à inscrire
la liberté des femmes à recourir à l'IVG
il a donc repris la formulation qui
avait été votée par le cénos ou
l'impulsion de célibat qui avait
d'ailleurs divisé la majorité
sénatoriale est-ce que vous auriez
préféré qu'il reprenne la formulation
droit à l'IVG qui était la formulation
initiale qui avait d'ailleurs été votée
à l'Assemblée
ah bah pas du tout pour deux raisons la
première c'est effectivement il semble
reprendre les termes qui sont ceux qui
ont été adoptés par le Sénat grâce à
l'amendement du sénateur LR Philippe Bas
que moi j'ai voté et qui consacre une
liberté de la femme dans le cadre de la
loi
et pas le texte précédent qui est tombé
et qui était qui présentait des risques
en termes d'équilibre par rapport à
l'équipe qui est compliqué à trouver sur
ce sujet et donc le texte du Sénat c'est
une bonne chose qui effectivement le
président de la République envoie un
signal fort en reprenant
la façon dont c'est écrit c'est pas de
moindre portée je dirais que c'est à
droit constant c'est à dire que c'est
l'objectif qui avait été fixé
constitutionnalisée à droit constant on
ne on modifie pas le droit constant
actuel en revanche on l'inscrit dans la
Constitution c'était ça qui était
proposé et c'est ça qui est fait par
l'amendement de Philippe Bas et qu'à
entraîné description de de la loi votée
par le Sénat le président de la
République qui souhaite englober ça dans
une réforme plus globale une réforme
constitutionnelle plus globale est-ce
qu'en faisant ça il prend pas le risque
d'enterrer cet IVG dans la Constitution
je ne sais pas alors si on dehors des
sujets sur l'IVG effectivement j'entends
parler de certains autres sujets moi je
suis
égalisation extrêmement sensible
protection effectivement de la
Constitution donc je suis comme beaucoup
de ceux qui considèrent qu'on doit
toucher la Constitution avec énormément
de précautions donc évidemment si si
c'est mis dans un package global ça
multiplie nécessairement le risque que
qu'il y ait des oppositions
devant le Congrès tous les jours tous
les 36 du mois non plus donc c'est sans
doute la seule solution mais ça
multiplie évidemment les oppositions
possibles
alors évidemment parler de ce qui se
passe au Sénat le Sénat qui poursuit
l'examen de la réforme des retraites
dans une ambiance
quelques peu électriques les débats se
sont enlisés hier soir récits de ces
dernières heures de séance avec Quentin
calme et qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin
de retour le matin après avoir suivi des
séances jusqu'au bout de la nuit vous
suivez les séances jour et nuit Quentin
avant de parler de l'ambiance le point
sur ce qui a été voté au Sénat hier
d'abord les sénateurs qui ont adopté le
dispositif carrière longue voilà on l'a
vu dans le reportage le sujet de Jérôme
Rabier effectivement par le cette mesure
qui permet aux Français qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt de partir à la retraite
avant l'âge de 64 ans alors on va pas
rentrer dans la mécanique complexe de ce
dispositif est-ce que c'est très
difficilement compréhensible la façon
dont ça fonctionne exactement d'ailleurs
hier René Paul Savary a essayé
d'expliquer ce tableau là qu'on voit à
l'antenne c'est à dire la prise en
compte de multiples facteurs et facteurs
d'âge les annuités etc simplement le
principe que l'on retient c'est que et
bien il va y avoir des dispositifs pour
permettre de partir à la retraite quand
vous avez cotisé 43 ou 44 ans si vous
avez commencé à travailler avant 20 ans
comme on le lit sur ce tableau dans la
partie orange la porte de la réforme
avec est-ce que les sénateurs sont en
train d'adopter et bien les sénateurs
ils ont même rajouté une nouvelle borne
d'âge à ce tableau hier en séance les
Français ayant commencé à travailler
entre 20 et 21 ans elles vont pouvoir
prendre leur retraite avec un départ
anticipé à 63 ans alors Emmanuel Capu
oui c'est ce que j'allais vous vous
demander comme question il était
important de lisser un peu plus ce
tableau on a entendu Jean-Marie van
lorenberg qui est pourtant centriste et
qui est donc au modem plutôt avec la
majorité et la majorité dire qu'on n'y
comprenait pas grand chose et que ce
serait difficilement compréhensible par
les Françaises qui se jouent avec ces
avec ces dispositifs carrière longue
est-ce que certains c'est
qu'effectivement c'est très très
difficilement compréhensible déjà pour
les parlementaires donc pour les
Français
même pour nous c'est compliqué donc pour
les Français c'est sûr que c'est
totalement incompréhensible donc ce
qu'il faut retenir ce qui est
intéressant est-ce que je pense les
Français n'ont pas du tout compris c'est
qu'avec le dispositif carrière longue
tout le monde ne part pas à 62 ans si
vous avez commencé tôt 64 ans pardon
tout le monde ne part pas à 64 ans on
peut partir beaucoup plus tôt c'est le
tableau que vous avez sous les yeux donc
oui moi je suis tout à fait favorable au
fait d'améliorer le texte c'est notre
rôle ici de lycée j'avais déposé un
amendement qui allait dans ce sens
qu'elle est un peu plus loin aussi qui
est tombé du coup par l'adoption de des
autres amendements mais c'est les débats
que nous avons ici pour améliorer le
texte pour le rendre un petit peu
compréhensible puis pour rappeler qu'en
fait avec la loi Touraine c'est déjà il
y a beaucoup de choses qui sont déjà le
cas avant et ça les Français je crois
n'ont absolument pas compris que d'ores
et déjà il risquait enfin il devait
travailler 43 années dans les
dispositifs avant la réforme est-ce
qu'il faut aller encore plus loin est-ce
qu'il faut 43 ans pour tous les Français
qui sont dans un dispositif carrière
long oui parce qu'on le voit excusez-moi
mais on le voit il y a une alternance
entre 43 44 ans en fonction de l'âge
avec auquel vous commencez à travailler
vous pouvez être mécaniquement perdant
et c'est assez arbitraire sur le nombre
d'annuités au total
moi c'est ce que j'avais c'est le sens
de l'amendement que j'avais déposé
notamment avec mes c'était le même que
les collègues horizons à l'Assemblée
nationale après ça fait partie je pense
des choses qui peuvent encore être
améliorées dans le cadre de la navette
aujourd'hui on a trouvé un accord hier
sur le dispositif tel qu'il a été voté
moi je suis je suis plutôt favorable à
une amélioration encore dans son sens là
donc ça peut être juste améliorer en CMP
parce que horizon et pour les députés
les républicains sont également pour la
gauche et pour vous pensez qu'en CMP
vous pouvez arriver à ce que tous les
Français dans un dispositif carrière
longue avec 43 ans
peut-être pas tous puisque ça dépend
vous l'avez vu il y a des il y a des
Français qui commencent encore plus tôt
donc ils vont cotiser forcément plus de
43 ans
là où ce serait moi ce que je ce que je
n'apprécie pas c'est le 10 c'est le
dispositif reposé par Aurélien Pradier
qui est démagogique
il faut la question c'est le nombre de
trimestres cotisés avant 20 ans en fait
on peut pas on comprend bien que c'est
pas parce que vous avez été étudiant et
vous allez faire un job d'été avant 21
ans que ça peut valider une année de
cotisation c'est là à mon avis où il y a
une difficulté en revanche
améliorer le texte pour qu'il y a un peu
plus de monde qui qui partent après 43
années ça me paraît tout à fait juste
autre mesure phare de la réforme des
retraites votées dans la version des
sénateurs cette fois content c'est cette
surcote pour les mères de famille voilà
la droite il tenait beaucoup
effectivement pour compenser certains
effets délétères de la réforme Bruno
Retailleau en avait même fait une ligne
rouge pour soutenir cette réforme des
retraites au Sénat et donc la majorité
sénatorielle hier en séance ajouter une
surcote pour les femmes ayant eu au
moins un enfant si elle travaille
jusqu'à 64 ans leur dernière année entre
63 et 64 ans leur fait gagner un bonus
sur leur pension jusqu'à 5% si elles ont
toutes leurs annuités bien sûr pendant
leur carrière fait important le Sénat à
adopter cette mesure à 280 voix pour et
aucune contre même si une partie de la
gauche c'est abstenu sur ce scrutin et
mais le Capu c'est la démonstration que
cette réforme elle pénalisait les femmes
et qu'il fallait la rééquilibrer et donc
en l'occurrence pour les maires de
famille
c'est pas tout à fait ça en fait la
réforme elle pénalise pas les femmes les
femmes sont pénalisées par leur carrière
qui sont hachées et par des
rémunérations qui sont moins élevées que
les hommes en moyenne de 35% moins bien
payés que que les hommes de fait
effectivement à partir du moment où vous
rallongez la durée de cotisation et ou
repousser l'âge de la retraite de fait
forcément ça augmente cette pénalisation
qui vient de la vie en fait de leur
carrière donc moi j'étais très favorable
à prendre en compte cette différence de
rémunération cette différence de
carrière et et la surcote me paraît un
bon mécanisme même si ça n'empêche pas
qu'il faut s'attaquer au fond du sujet
qui n'est pas celui des retraites mais
celui de des égalités d'égalité des
rémunérations et des carrières-achées
juste la gauche elle dénonce le fait que
et bien on s'occupe des femmes qui ont
eu un enfant et qu'effectivement on
s'occupe pas de toutes les femmes avec
cette mesure et donc du coup il y a
comme ça euh un peu une politique
nathaliste qui fait penser à une forme
conservatrice de la vision de de la
société qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous là c'est pareil c'est la loi
actuelle c'est ce sont les femmes qui
ont arrêté de travailler pour s'occuper
de leurs enfants qui étaient le qui
était qui sont le plus pénalisés
aujourd'hui pas par la réforme par le
système par répartition actuelle donc
faut en retenir compte en revanche et
j'ai déjà en fait répondu à votre
question en réalité c'est la politique
vis-à-vis de l'égalité de la
rémunération l'égalité homme-femme elle
est beaucoup plus large c'est pas dans
la loi sur les retraites qu'on va la
régler et Quentin on va voir ce qui
s'est passé dans la soirée puisque c'est
reparti de plus belle sur la suite des
articles et des nouvelles tensions
d'électriser les missyclières exactement
hier en séance comme on le voit depuis
maintenant trois jours effectivement on
est passé à l'article 9 donc après tous
ces éléments qu'on vient d'évoquer c'est
et bien la prise en compte de la
pénibilité qui était débattue en
transmets la droite a voulu accélérer
les débats et faire tomber c'est à dire
supprimer une myriade d'amendement venu
de la gauche patatras cette gauche a
refusé de se laisser faire écouter
Claude Raynal en séance hier je vous
signale simplement un seul mot il y a 70
amendements qui vont tomber ça aurait
fait 70 prise de parole sur le sujet qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui on va le
remplacer par 70 règles
rappels du règlement c'est intelligent
et c'est de droit alors c'est
intelligent moi j'aimerais plutôt qu'on
enlève ça et qu'on travaille au fond
voilà on voit ce faux rythme qui
s'installe au Sénat depuis trois jours
des moments où on débat sur le fond et
des moments où il y a des procédures des
voilà l'utilisation du Règlement du
Sénat pour contraindre les débats et
dans ces cas-là c'est des vagues qui
deviennent électriques écoutez René Paul
Savary qui est donc le rapporteur de la
branche vieillesse qui parle au nom de
la droite dans l'hémicycle pour lui la
gauche refuse d'avancer contrairement à
ce qu'elle aurait promis initialement le
Sénat devait attendre la mobilisation du
7 mars pour et bien passer à l'article 7
et ensuite avancer et la gauche ne
respecte pas ce pacte selon lui écouter
René Paul Savage moi dans la vie on m'a
appris qu'on récoltait ce qu'on allait
semer
et vous avez récolté vous récoltez ce
que vous avez semé la semaine dernière
vous avez
vous n'avez pas tenu vos engagements et
quand on tient pas les engagements
demandez à vos présidents de groupe ils
savent bien de quoi je parle
demandez-leur ne criez pas comme ça
tenez-vous engagements il était bien
question que l'on puisse débattre du
texte pour aller jusqu'au bout du texte
voilà finalement un amendement de la
droite et du centre a bien été adopté en
fin de séance c'était vers minuit et
demi mais le débat autour de la
pénibilité ne fait que commencer et il
continue aujourd'hui et tout comme les
tensions dans l'hémicycle Emmanuel Capu
c'est un degré d'énervement rarement
atteint autour de cette réforme qui se
joue depuis trois jours en séance vous
êtes d'accord ça devient extrêmement
compliqué parce que hier soir on n'a pas
pu avancer d'un iota d'un iota on devait
parler de la pénibilité on devait parler
de l'usure professionnelle on ne devait
parler des gens qui travaillent dur qui
travaillent la nuit qui travaillent dans
le froid qui traque qui porte des
charges c'était ça le sujet hier et on
devait améliorer leur sort c'est quand
même notre rôle essayez de trouver les
solutions pour que le texte prenne mieux
en compte la pénibilité l'usure
professionnelle et l'article 9 c'est la
création de nouveaux droits de nouveaux
moyens pour lutter contre ça au lieu de
ça qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on à
quoi on fait face 70 amendements
identiques ils étaient tous identiques
moi je les ai on nous a distribués 70
amendements quasiment des copiés collés
certains a été quelques virgule près
différentes 70 amendements non seulement
pour supprimer l'article 9 qui crée des
droits pour les salariés ce qui est déjà
un vrai problème et deux qui sont
identiques qui font uniquement perdre du
temps et quand la Commission fait ce
qu'elle a à faire c'est à dire elle met
la priorité pour éventuellement faire
tomber les amendements suivants et pour
faire avancer les débats conformément
parce que ce qui est intéressant c'est
que René Paul Savary a expliqué pourquoi
est-ce qu'on était obligé d'accélérer
parce que pendant 5 jours il y a
visiblement eu un accord entre les
présidents de groupe pour dire ok on
avance tranquillement jusqu'au jour de
la du 7 mars pour des raisons qui vous
appartiennent les groupes d'oppositions
vous avez envie de discuter de l'article
7 après le 7 mars après la manifestation
tant mieux pour vous on le la majorité
accepte très aimablement c'est un
gentleman agrément et juste après
qu'est-ce qu'on observe on observe en
fait le gentleman agrément visiblement
n'est absolument pas respecté
aujourd'hui vous avez une opposition
systématique complètement stupide enfin
on a eu des débats lunaires Claude
Reynal est un des plus modéré vous avez
vu ensuite tous ces collègues faire des
rappels au réglement totalement abscons
sur l'article 44 bis sur l'article 46
bis surtout et n'importe quoi plutôt que
de débattre mais vous verrez la
pénibilité et de accepter cet accord du
coup et de l'usure préférée
minoritaire je ne suis pas sur soi en
conférence des présidents que ce soit
passé je pense que c'est ça c'est fait
plutôt entre les présidents caner
Gontard et
directement effectivement avec d'autres
qui est certain ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
manifestement l'accord n'est pas du tout
respecté par par les autres qui
maintenant clairement un objectif qui
était limpide hier et certains l'ont dit
d'ailleurs à votre micro je vois Daniel
broyer il a été très clair et très très
sympathique il a pas dit il a dit nous
notre objectif unique c'est que le vote
n'est pas lieu d'être maintenant je
crois que c'est très clair les groupes
de l'opposition ne veulent pas que le
vote et lui et donc ils font tout voilà
pour faire durer les débats hier soir on
s'est couché il y avait quasiment plus
d'amendements que le matin quand on est
arrivé oui puisque les sénateurs peuvent
déposer déposer des sous amendements
effectivement pendant la séance mais
vous êtes d'accord pour dire que c'est
une forme de guérilla parlementaire qui
se joue elle a le droit de sénatoriale
qui use du règlement article 38 pour
contraindre le nombre de prises de
parole ce dépôt de sous-amendement la
commission qui fait voter en priorité
ces amendements à elle pour faire tomber
des sous amendements c'est une forme de
on perd le fil avec le débat sur les
retraites c'est un truc tout à fait
nouveau au Sénat et c'est sûr sur quoi
j'ai alerté hier mes collègues des
groupes de position ça n'est pas du tout
la tradition du Sénat c'est vrai la
tradition du Sénat c'est même si on est
contre un texte d'essayer de l'améliorer
et en tout état de cause de le voter de
voter contre si on est contre mais
d'essayer de montrer que nous ne sommes
pas à l'Assemblée nationale que nous
nous écoutons et que nous votons les
textes en ayant exprimé mais aussi la
tradition au Sénat c'est le respect de
l'opposition et là il est plus il est
plus respecté l'opposition et
extrêmement respectée ça fait je dis
vendredi samedi dimanche lundi mardi
mercredi jeudi on est vendredi qu'on
écoute jour et nuit des soliloques
totalement hors sujet parfois sur soit
des rappels au règlement sans aucun
rapport avec le sujet soit sur des
amendements qui n'ont que pour but de
faire tomber de faire perdre du temps
quand vous avez 70 orateur différents
qui répètent le même amendement rédigé
de la même façon ça n'a aucun intérêt en
fait faut leur expliquer on peut
consigner les amendements si on veut bon
et du coup en attendant l'horloge tourne
pour arriver dimanche minuit est-ce que
pour vous le gouvernement doit prolonger
un peu les débats pour aller un peu
au-delà de dimanche minute et la journée
de lundi par exemple en fait on fait 5
ans et demi que je suis sénateur j'ai
pas souvenir qu'on est passé autant de
temps à part sur des PLF sur un texte
c'est un texte extrêmement important qui
concerne les Français les règles du jeu
elles sont fixées depuis le début le
président l'archet a ouvert comme jamais
les séances on travaille
longtemps deux jours de nuit le samedi
le dimanche faut-il ouvrir du coup
dimanche après dimanche pardon il faut
ouvrir au maximum et puis lundi faut pas
ouvrir après le planche dim les règles
elles sont posées depuis le départ donc
évidemment non
un mot parce que après il y aura une CMP
une commission mixparitaire donc il va
chercher un accord entre députés
moi ce que je veux dire parce que c'est
extrêmement important c'est que le petit
jeu des groupes d'opposition extrêmement
dangereux pour la démocratie pourquoi
parce que on perd l'image que nous
avions jusqu'à maintenant très
clairement d'une assemblée sérieuse qui
travaille et qui propose on rentre dans
une sorte comme vous l'avez dit de
guérilla qui est pas du tout l'usage et
qui donne une image détestable ce qui
fait que les Français vont se dire que à
l'Assemblée nationale comme au Sénat on
a des gens qui sont pas responsables et
qui ne prennent pas leur responsabilité
moi je pense que le Sénat doit prendre
ses responsabilités qu'il doit voter oui
ou non et qu'ensuite effectivement de
façon démocratique on arrive à une
décision en CMP et qu'on soit pas eu
obligé d'utiliser des instruments qui ne
sont normalement pas utilisés et qui
sont pas des bons enfin qui sont pas les
meilleurs instruments un dernier mot sur
l'équilibre financier de cette réforme
parce que c'est important et ça ça fait
partie des choses auxquelles vous tenez
est-ce que là Olivier du soft dimanche
dernier a déjà alerté sur le fait qu'à
l'horizon 2030 il allait manquer 300 ou
400 millions d'euros est-ce que le
gouvernement a trop cédé est-ce qu'il
faut revoir l'équilibre financier de
cette réforme ça c'est sûr que mon
groupe Les Indépendants on est
extrêmement sensible à l'équilibre parce
que ça ça sera la pire des choses c'est
que non seulement on arrive pas à voter
mais qu'en plus par souci du consensus
on est une réforme qui ne rapporte pas
assez d'économies et c'est bien ça
l'enjeu c'est pour ça que cette réforme
elle est utile c'est pour qu'on préserve
pour chacun une retraite à des niveaux
corrects de pension et sans que en
trouvant un équilibre donc c'est ça
l'enjeu c'est pour ça qu'il faut donc il
faut d'autres économies il faut pas
d'autres économies il faut arrêter je
pense faut trouver un équilibre il faut
faire attention à l'équilibre général et
il faut effectivement
ne pas en rajouter systématiquement
parce qu'on voit qu'en plus ça n'est pas
payé de retour
moi je trouve objectivement que jusqu'à
maintenant l'attitude est très
l'attitude est plutôt responsable il y a
une position qui est assez claire et un
accord
qui est tout à fait correct entre les
positions des LR et la maladie la
majorité présidentielle merci Quentin
merci on va reparler de ce débats
électriques dans l'hémicycle ce sera à
suivre dans le club on va continuer à
parler de cette réforme avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Chartres où on trouve Sébastien Baez
bonjour Sébastien merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédacteur en chef de l'écho
républicain Sébastien vous revenez dans
vos pages sur l'impact du mouvement de
contestation de cette réforme sur le
quotidien de vos lecteurs
oui dans les quotidiens du groupe Centre
France nous en chantons ce matin sur la
mobilisation des éboueurs et la
mobilisation dans les industries
électriques et gazières et donc ces
impacts sur le quotidien l'enjeu pour
ces grévistes c'est la défense de leur
régime spéciaux une grève des éboueurs
de la ville de Paris a commencé lundi
depuis on l'a vu les poubelles
s'accumulent dans la rue dans la moitié
des arrondissements des éboueurs
occupent aussi et l'usine d'incinération
de la Porte d'Ivry environ 2000 tonnes
de déchets ils sont traités tous les
jours la grève des éboueurs ne touche
pas seulement Paris c'est aussi le cas
par exemple dans l'agglomération de
Sophia antipo police dans les
Alpes-Maritimes du côté des industries
gazières et électriques en Île-de-France
les usines d'incinération sont à l'arrêt
à Saint-Ouen Ivry-sur-Seine et
Issy-les-Moulineaux ce sont des usines
qui brûlent les déchets pour les
transformer en énergie alors selon Régis
Bitche et lui le secrétaire général CGT
et nettoiement éboueur la ville de Paris
plus aucun déchet en Île-de-France ne
serait actuellement traité conséquence
il y a on l'a dit lamoncellement des
ordures mais aussi selon un autre
syndicaliste en cas de grand les usines
d'incinération pourraient jusqu'à priver
et les Parisiens de chauffage la
mobilisation des éboueurs régissent
vicelli affirme qu'elle se poursuivra
jusqu'au retrait de la réforme pourquoi
parce que pour lui cette réforme est un
non-sens qui fait valoir l'espérance de
vie des éboueurs d'où sortent de moins
qu'un autre travailleur selon lui un
éboueur peut être actuellement
prétendant à la retraite à 57 ans
personne ne part à cet âge-là addit-il
donne l'exemple d'un collègue qu'il a
récemment à rencontrer un collègue de 63
ans ça fait deux ans qu'il est à la
retraite et il a toutes les maladies du
monde assure le syndicaliste qui conclut
la retraite à 64 ans en pour un grand
nombre d'entre nous c'est la mort assuré
au boulot bonjour Emmanuel Capu bonjour
alors les syndicats avaient promis de
mettre le pays à l'arrêt le 7 mars
pensez-vous que le blocage de la France
pourrait finalement se trouver devant
nous
j'espère pas j'espère pas je constate
qu'il y a une forte mobilisation 7 mars
mais qu'elle n'a pas été beaucoup plus
forte que les fois d'avant je constate
que les deux dans les grèves ont pas été
pour le coup ont été beaucoup moins
suivis dans la fonction publique
notamment que précédemment donc moi
j'espère un retour à la normale le plus
rapidement possible j'espère d'abord un
vote du texte vous l'avez compris et
puis ensuite une fois que le texte sera
voté qu'on retourne à la normale parce
que notamment ce que ce que ce que vous
avez dit je rappelle quand même qu'on a
décidé de ne pas supprimer les régimes
spéciaux on a décidé de fermer 5 régimes
spéciaux avec la clause du grand-père
c'est à dire sur 40 années donc en fait
personne n'est affecté aucun des
salariés actuels des industries gazières
de l'ensemble des cinq régimes qui sont
concernés ne sont affectés par la
réforme
parce que Bruno Retailleau veut
accélérer cette suppression des bas à
venir dans les prochaines heures et vous
êtes pour ou pas faites l'accélération
moi je suis plus mitigé dans l'absolu
par principe évidemment les régimes
spéciaux en vocation a disparaître et
plutôt plus rapidement que ce que le
texte propose dans tous les cas c'est la
position de mon groupe régulièrement
dans le contexte actuel dans le contexte
que vient de rappeler votre collègue je
pense que la position qui est proposée
par le gouvernement qui est un compromis
avec ce qu'on appelle la clause du
grand-père c'est à dire une extinction
assez longue me paraît raisonnable donc
c'est pour ça et ça sera ma position
dans l'examen de ce texte est-ce que
vous pensez que le vote si votre il y a
ça va accentuer ça va radicaliser la
contestation ou au contraire ça va les
tendre
moi je pense que les Français ils ont
compris que cette réforme elle était
indispensable et qu'elle allait se faire
et donc je j'espère que le vote va
mettre un terme à la contestation
non mais personne n'est pour
vous comme moi quand on nous dit qu'il
va falloir peut-être travailler deux ans
de plus c'est pas agréable et on en a
pas envie personne n'a envie de
travailler sauf quelques exceptions mais
la grande majorité des Français ils
n'ont pas envie de cette réforme
c'est pas ce que je dis je dis que
beaucoup en leur fort intérieur savent
qu'elle est indispensable et qu'elle
permettra de garantir des retraites pour
leurs enfants pour leurs petits-enfants
merci beaucoup romain merci Sébastien
merci Sébastien la Une de l'écho
républicain pour une maison plus économe
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Sébastien Besse et merci
Emmanuel Capu d'être venu on va
évidemment continuer à suivre sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat vos débats
dans l'hémicycle ça dure jusqu'à
dimanche minuit merci beaucoup Emmanuel
Capy d'avoir été avec nous et dans 20
minutes dans le club on va revenir sur
l'examen de ce texte au Sénat on en
parle d'ailleurs tout de suite avec
notre chaîne invité c'est Erico